are you playing custom obviously you
okay pal you seem sad well I made the
mistake of watching battlestar galactica
again because 10th anniversary of the TV
reboot and you know it was my first love
and I'm sad and I'm just not over it you
do realize it's just the TV show right
it is so much more than that okay help
me cut off the corners of these pieces
of paper why cuz it was just a thing
that they did okay battle saw doesn't
need to explain itself to mere mortals
like us I genuinely spend a lot of my
time wondering what life would be like
if there was a good battle star game you
really need to get out more I know there
have been officially licensed battle
star games before but like the matrix
equals they might as well have not
existed but trinity my love well there
was the mobile game the completely
devoid of voiceover Xbox Live and PC
title and most recently BSG online a
free-to-play MMO where you dog fight in
mine till IAM to your heart's content
but real talk those games aren't good at
all the real crux of the show is the
intriguing and twisting plot the looming
end of humanity politics ridiculously
good-looking robots theology that guy
from Bridget Jones and guessing who in
the hell is a Cylon everyone's favorite
space soap opera mass effect is good
though and it's the nearest thing we've
got to a great battle star game I mean
it certainly borrows a lot from BSG like
half its cast I enjoy the sight of
humans on their DS by OS trilogy does an
amazing job of showcasing an
all-encompassing end of the universe as
we know it humanity must prevail robot
rebellion scenario with a healthy dash
of politics action and sexy synthetic
ladies I do love the synthetic ladies
but one thing it's missing is proper
space navigation what about the Normandy
normally doesn't count there's nothing
to replicate the Galactica cruise
desperate search with a safe haven of
Earth or any way to recreate the epic
battles of Viper squadrons vs. Cylon
Raiders there's no rap to recon missions
and the
certainly no massive Cylon base stars to
board an infiltrate fan-made free space
to mod diaspora shattered armistice is a
great example of nailing the tone and
frenetic gameplay of dog fighting in
Galactica and look Starbuck herself is
going to be an eval curry add in a bit
of a leap dangerous or no man's sky for
the scrabbling around finding habitable
planets bit and boom you've got yourself
a Battlestar game worthy of the name I
guess what I'm getting at is so many
games borrow from Battlestar and yet it
doesn't have a quality game to call its
own imagine playing is a member of the
colonial fleet or the mysterious Cylon
models 7 you choose to either save
humanity or destroy it and this doesn't
exist yet so that's why I'm slowly
trying to come fatly Adama one jar of
Nutella at a time you know other sci-fi
exists not everything has to be a game
life's a game can stop it I'll see you
next week
you